Daniel Ellsberg the whistleblower who
released the Pentagon Papers in 1971 has
studied the dangers of nuclear conflict
for decades it's the basis for his book
the doomsday machine confessions of a
nuclear war planner we sat down with him
to discuss the origins of nuclear war
plans and today's crises for more than
40 years Daniel Ellsberg has been known
as the man who exposed the US government
secrets about the Vietnam War I did this
clearly but there's an even bigger
secret he's been keeping about his
involvement in planning for an even
bigger war you said I was part of a plan
that should never have been made that
was a crime against humanity what was
the plan the plan was to hit every city
in the Soviet Union and every city in
China there was no plan for the fighting
Soviets that did not also involve
annihilating the Chinese population the
result was a readiness to annihilate 600
million people a hundred Holocaust when
I say crime against humanity it was
actually a crime against the existence
of the human species this is the end of
days and that was the plan yes I pray
that the coming years will be blessed
with peace and prosperity in the 1960s
it was Ellsberg's job to update the
nuclear plans left by President
Eisenhower you've said this was the most
evil plan that ever existed and yet the
people that you knew who drafted this
plan were they a moral no it what this
reveal to me was something about our
species that I've had to live with the
next 50 years and try to understand
their very normal ordinary smart
conscientious patriotic people working
in secret can carry out monstrous plans
but it's the job and you go to work and
job and you do what the boss wants when
I modified these plans or I for instance
tried to get the targeting off cities
and also Moscow and
China automatically and actually I
failed in all that not hitting Moscow
was just unthinkable
ellsberg compares the war plans to the
1964 movie dr. Strangelove which centers
on the existence of a doomsday machine
meant to automatically respond to a
first-strike attack with enough nuclear
weapons to destroy all life on Earth and
dr. Strangelove was a documentary it saw
the mad humor in this situation gee I
wish we had one of them doomsday
machines painting it still makes me
laugh when I think about it because it's
hard to take this seriously except that
it's very serious indeed those were and
are our preparations for nuclear war he
intended to bring the information to the
public after the close of the war in
Vietnam but found publishers then and 30
years later feeling we can't sell this
to readers they don't want to hear
anything with the word nuclear in the
title and that was true right up until
the present more than 50 years later
Ellsberg has published a new book about
his experience he wrote the book in his
bunker like office referencing documents
from his considerable archives so there
are a few books down here just a few and
you've created your own library
classification system nuclear knows
first use these are the threats of
French human to live and a lot of notes
Wow it's a chapter of the book and this
is a draft dated 1995 so people ask me -
why have you waited to put this stuff on
well the truth is I've put it out in
lectures and sometimes trying to get it
out by special means like getting
arrested you justify putting out all
these secrets this time nobody story
but the world is paying attention now
North Korean leader Kim jong-un has been
testing intercontinental ballistic
missiles they will be met with fire and
fury President Trump has threatened the
full force of the US military and
Russian President Vladimir Putin this
week shocked the world unveiling an
updated weapon system including a new
ICBM that he says is invincible
does the brinkmanship feel different
this time around
no not really the Brickman ship has been
there as I've said it was a way of using
nuclear weapons without pulling the
trigger using a gun at someone's head in
a confrontation without pulling the
trigger you're using the gun and to say
we haven't used these weapons or that
they've proved useless is simply
misleading Trump and Kim are both using
their weapons right now and one or the
other may back down or not
Putin is making similar first two
threats his are threats of crazy action
just as ours are and that doesn't
unfortunately mean that they will never
be carried out now 86 Ellsberg and his
wife Patricia have been privately living
with this knowledge for as long as their
nearly 50-year marriage today it's their
fellow citizens who are also living on
edge
Hawaii inadvertently sent out a message
alerting residents to an incoming
missile attack it was a false alarm what
Hawaii did the alert was to make a
million or so Hawaiian citizens aware
for the first time all the kinds of
dangers that we have all in the world
including
for half a century without thinking
about them and what to do some dive into
manholes many people interesting we sat
in bathtubs a total symbolic action it's
not what I would have done what would
you have done oh I would have invited
Patricia to lie down with me and kiss
for as long as the alarm went on and if
it didn't have on we would have had a
good half-hour is it a miracle that we
haven't had a nuclear house yes miracles
do happen and by that I don't mean just
it was unlikely but it was hard to
imagine if you knew what the real risks
were it's not impossible that there'll
be another 70 years it would take
another miracle what I'm working at is
your Triton alerting people to the
danger before the alarm sounds to do
something about it
so that the risk will be somewhat less
you know we're so I think in trance and
preoccupied with domestic policy
policies and politics but there is a lot
happening in this world well as he
points out this risk has been there for
half a century and we've really not
stared it in the face and our
geopolitical adversaries in many ways
remain the same we are still talking
about Russia in the nuclear arms race
and and and dr. Strangelove is a
documentary we should all pay attention
to